bassem quel est l'objectif de cette
conférence
et qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre
effectivement grégory donc là à munich
la capitale bavaroise s'apprête le temps
d'un week end être la capitale
internationale de la diplomatie plus de
500 leaders du monde de la politique de
la sécurité du renseignement ou encore
de la société civile sont attendus ici
deux jours pour débattre et discuter de
la sécurité internationale de la
sécurité européenne il s'agira aussi d
confie qu est telle que la libye
énormément de chefs d'état mais aussi de
chef de la diplomatie sont attendus
justin trudeau du canada emmanuel macron
sergueï lavrov ou encore le chef de la
diplomatie iranienne
beaucoup d'américains seront présents et
c'est assez exceptionnel car on attend
nancy pelosi mac pomper ou encore mc
espère et beaucoup de parlementaires
américains également seront sur place
sergueï lavrov emmanuel macron devrait
prendre la parole demain sa gueule à
broc devrait arriver aujourd'hui donc il
sera question de sécurité est un enjeu
crucial pour les européens c'est
d'essayer de pallier à cette perte
d'influencé progressive de l'occident
face au reste du monde donc énormément
de tables rondes seront organisées des
panels et qu'également sur différentes
thématiques donc énormément de
personnalités la ville et qui a brillé
sous haute sécurité pour attendre ses
nombreuses personnalités politiques
donc on va essayer de revenir bien
évidemment au courant de la journée sur
cet événement international et
diplomatique
ici à munich en attendant l'arrivée de
certaines personnalités aujourd'hui on
devrait attendre justin trudeau et nancy
pelosi qui devrait prendre la parole en
attendant bien sûr d'écouter les autres
délégations qui prendront la parole
durant tout ce week-end autour de la
sécurité
merci à ben hassen chébili en direct
donc de munich